welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
and it's time to ratchet up the tension
with the prequel to one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
i kind of have mixed feelings about the
season and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down its entire
plot
how it aligns with the movie's story our
thoughts on it and the show's ending
there's gonna be heavy spoilers here for
both the show and film
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
them yet then you'd have to be
insane to keep watching this video
terrible terrible jokes as always but
drop a thumbs up
if you enjoy the crap now without the
way thank you for clicking this
let's get into ratched okay so ratchet
takes place
before the events of one flew over the
cuckoo's nest in the movie we followed
an older version of ratched
as she faced off against randall
mcmurphy played by jack nicholson
rachid was very stoic throughout the
film and she barely showed any emotion
she represented taking away one's
individuality
and she very much forced the patients to
conform to order
juxtaposing this randall taught them to
express themselves
to disobey the rules and ultimately get
the most out of life
the film culminated with randall
attacking ratchet
and eventually he was lobotomized
because of it
randall had become emotionless almost
similar to ratchet
and i remember this felt like a real gut
punch the first time i saw the film
however in an act of mercy randall was
killed by another patient known as the
chief
who'd promised to escape with him though
he could have been a slave to the system
metaphorically this suffocation allowed
randall to escape the confines of the
asylum in death
and the film ended with the chief
breaking out of this prison showing that
both characters had escaped the cage
they'd been forced into
the series sort of follows this motif
however it ends
very much in the opposite way to the
film with ratchet in a position where
she should be free
but instead she's haunted by fear now in
the finale she overcomes it
and realizes that she won't be a slave
to the trappings of our own mind
and the season is very much about facing
things head on instead of running away
from them
we'll get into it all in just a bit but
predominantly we follow mildred ratched
played by sarah paulsen as she slowly
transforms into the character we love to
hate
the season opens with the murder of a
priesthouse which is carried out by
edmund tulson
aka the clergy killer he becomes
integral to the plot
but early on we see the contradiction in
the church as
one of the priests is supposed to be
celibate but he keeps an underwear
catalogue under his bed
i've never seen such lewd imagery now
the church was very much tied to the
film
and at one point there was even a
patient that took medication like it was
communion
showing that the movie was commenting on
the ties between the institution and the
church
in the show nurses are referred to god's
angels they dress in attire similar to
nuns
and pretty much oversee the operations
at the institution
the church very much tells people how to
live their lives
and mirroring this the asylum forces
people to act in a certain way
we learn the clergy though thought to be
compassionate
simply were not and similar to this we
see ratchet go on a journey in which
he's required to help people
but in fact does the opposite most of
the time ratchet manipulates her way
into working in the hospital
which is also used as grounds for a
talking point to get the governor
reelected but it doesn't really go
anywhere as do
a lot of the plot points in the season
now throughout the series
she poisons the patients with overdoses
in order to make herself seem like a
savior
talks them into ending their life and oh
my god is that jeffrey
jeffrey my man oh no now she oversees
the lobotomy being made commonplace
and we know from our own history that
this operation was done to pretty much
leave
someone in an almost constantly sedated
state
ratchet would of course come to use a
lobotomy on randall
and seeing this seed planted here is a
pretty terrifying watch
we see how excessive treatment is used
on a lesbian as
this was looked upon as a disordered
mind but then ratchet herself falls in
love with a woman named gwendolyn
once more showing the contradiction
between treatment and those using it
i kind of feel that though this is true
to paulson's personality
it's gonna anger some fans who viewed
ratched as more of an
asexual machine-like person that was
completely unfeeling
and unsympathetic however i think it's
handled pretty well here
and seeing her admitted in episode 7
does feel genuine
even though it's not necessarily close
to the source material
now a big reveal that comes early on is
that mildred and edmund are in fact
foster siblings
we learn that mildred's mother became an
alcoholic during the great depression
and decided to put her in foster care
along with edmund the two were brought
up by abusive parents
and here they formed a bond child
services stepped in and took them out of
the house
and a kind case worker there decided
that they should stay together
and she put on the paperwork that they
were blood relatives the pair ended up
going from home to home
suffering worse and worse abuse and this
eventually made edmond gouge out the
eyes of the pair that exploited them to
child predators
mildred ran into the night and then they
were split up
from this you kind of get the feeling of
why ratchet is the way she is
and this could be handled with some real
gravitas that i think would have
brilliantly tied into the original
however it's just so hammed about points
that it's difficult to really feel like
the ratchet we see here
would go on to be the one in the movie
it's a far cry from the film
and as someone that was such a big fan
of the original i have to say
i just felt on the whole that tone was
too camp for moments like this
to be taken seriously so in my head this
just
isn't canon they tell her origin story
really creatively with the puppet show
and then for some reason tell the exact
same story again in a monologue
which just felt so baffling to me that i
have no idea why it wasn't edited out
to see ratchet turn into someone that
operates in the shadows
secretly lobotomizing people was almost
a stretch too far
and i much preferred the grounded take
that the movie had in that she was
terrifying because she was allowed
and enabled by the system to carry out
horrendous acts
whereas here she feels like she's a sort
of villain of the week
that's comically carrying out crimes the
soundtrack of cape fear
ryan murphy has brought over his style
from american horror story
and yeah when a character is relieving
edmund through jail cell bars
it feels like a big departure from the
source material
things are made eye-rollingly bad by the
story centered around sharon stone and
her son henry
and we learn that thereafter the head
physician dr hanover
but this this plot feels completely
pointless looking back
he has a big arc with a hit man named
charles hunting him down
but it doesn't really go anywhere in the
end and even talking about it feels like
needless padding in the video
i think the main problem i have with the
show is that none of the characters are
likable
whereas in the film you had a range of
patience that all had their own
charismatic
aspects here it feels a bit hard to get
attached because
just how bad everyone is early on now we
head into the latter part of the season
with ratched
getting the position of head nurse after
she blackmails hannover
this ousts the current head nurse bucket
who though
initially a villain becomes quite a
sympathetic character as we get into it
hanover publicly embarrasses her at an
organized dance at the hospital
and mildred enacts a plan with her
brother however this
escalates with edmond killing a party
member and in the chaos gwendolyn is
shot by a nurse called dolly
whom ed had seduced they flee into the
night and lay low at a barn
whilst the police start to look for them
i got a lot of joker and harley quinn
vibes with the pair
and dolly goes out in a blaze of glory
trying to protect edmund
it completely embarrasses the hospital
and the governor comes down hard on
hanover
completely overlooking his curing of a
patient with multiple personality
disorder
named charlotte wells the governor
forces him to sign a paper saying that
edmund is sane
and fit to stand trial moving up his
execution
now like most american horror story
seasons the show
sort of has two endings and though
episode seven feels like
it would be the perfect way to close
things out we get two entries
bucket goes to ratchet with recordings
of a lobotomizing the only witness to
edmund's crimes
and we discovered that ratchet lied in
order to become a nurse
during the war she became an angel of
death that suffocated soldiers in acts
of mercy
bucky could expose her but instead she
extends an olive branch and this leads
to them working together to get funding
for the hospital
and in doing so bucket also takes over
hanover's job
hanover leaves his position and takes
charlotte with him but she takes a turn
for the worse and one of her darker
personalities comes out
and this kills hanover i think i think
the personality was also jesse owens as
they mentioned winning loads of gold
medals against hitler but
this season's so weird anyway ratched
sends sensor off on a bus
which probably not the best thing to do
with a person who's got multiple
personality disorder and has just killed
someone
but i suppose you're not a real nurse
and she takes hanover's head to lenore
in order to complete their deal
and get the money they agreed on this
allows her and gwendolyn to ride off
into the sunset
and we'll get into this in just a bit
now the caseworker who originally put
edmund and mildred together returns
and we discover that the reason edmund
carried out the murders on the clergy in
the first place
was because they were complicit in the
rape of his real mother before he was
moved into the foster system
mildred had tracked him down but he lied
about his release date so that he
wouldn't be talked out of the killings
he also still holds a grudge against her
due to her running away the night that
he killed those that were abusing them
mildred was meant to be there for him
but she just fled
and thus edmund feels like she betrayed
him whilst he gave
everything to save her life edmund lied
because he just couldn't trust her
i think in this moment mildred realizes
how much a lie can damage someone
which is a real change for her pretty
much throughout her entire life
she's believed that the way to survive
is by twisting the truth for your own
benefit
because of how she's grown up though the
caseworker is a kind person
had she not lied about them being
brother and sister in order to allow
them to move together
it's likely that mildred would never
have become caught up in edmonds actions
and crimes
these crimes caused her to commit her
own and the lies just spiraled out of
control
had she not lied about her skills in
order to become a nurse
then she would have never been ousted
and thus put on the path that we see in
the film
she's pretty much lied at every possible
opportunity and ran away from the truth
which plays massively into the ending
ratchet ultimately wants to euthanize
edmund
and strikes up a plan to do this
promising to see animals with him
this is of course another lie and the
further betrayal really hammers home
how she should have just told the truth
in the first place i feel like the
finale is really poking holes in the
institution
and we see how bucket has brought in
highly underqualified people to work
with the patients
though i don't feel like she's the bad
guy she's pretty much just making the
same mistakes as everyone in the
institution makes
and these errors would of course lead to
the events of the film being enabled
the state being useless is shown in an
execution that goes all green mile
and it cements that those deciding the
lives of these people in their care
simply do not have the know-how to do so
ratched like many of the nurses that she
works with
is completely out of her depth when it
comes to dealing with the mentally ill
and it feels like she'd rather run away
from it or take the easy way out
this is exemplified in her wanting to
give edmund a merciful death
like how she did to the soldiers in the
war but similar to that it backfires
with her having to leave her post
and going to hiding now a big spanner in
the works comes with the return of
charlotte wells
after taking a gun from hanover's desk
she goes in a rampage to get to edmond
and during this he discovers mildred's
plan to euthanize him
charlotte breaks out with edmund and we
have another time jump of two years
which is where we join mildred and
gwendolyn in mexico
after inviting nurse bucket to their
home we realize that mildred is
extremely paranoid
and in some ways developing her own
mental illness
over the fear of her brother returning
along with charlotte his killings have
continued
with seven nurses being murdered in
chicago however
this is actually a reference to richard
speck who carried this crime out in real
life
though it wasn't until 1966. edmund
calls her to threaten her
but mildred stands aground and tells him
that he should be afraid
mildred promises that she's coming for
him and we realized that it was her old
landlord that sold her out
they hit the road after her which ends
the season and though it seems like
ratchet is gonna be looking over her
shoulder i actually think she'll come
out triumphant
now the series as a whole is very much
about her running away from things
and how that ultimately doesn't work in
the film randall claimed to be insane in
order to escape jail
and he believed that a mental
institution would be an easier life for
him
but ultimately it wasn't the same thing
happened with ratchet
and whether it was a brother when they
were fostered or how she flees to mexico
she's realized that one could not truly
escape their actions and they will
always be haunted
i think here finally facing up to this
is the character coming full circle
and rather than fleeing once more which
is what the old mildred would have done
she's going to stand her ground i think
next time that she will indeed take
edmund down
but gwendolyn will get killed in the
crossfire as will bucket
ratchet basically needs to be forced to
go back into caring for those with
mental health issues
and in some ways she needs to be angry
at them deep down
in order to allow the treatment that she
did in the film
to me this is only possible if she
somewhat blames the mentally ill like
edmund for ruining her life
we have seen that she can be
compassionate to those with issues
so in order for things to go the way
they do she must have everything
stripped away
i'm not sure whether i want another
season but at the moment that's
that's how i can see it going if they
indeed decide to tie into the film
which they might they might not even do
now as for my thoughts on it
i just feel like in the end there was a
lot of filler here
that didn't really amount to much there
was a needless cancer story
dr hanover went out like a chump and the
latter part of the entry feels so
disconnected from the first it's almost
jarring thinking back on what happened
i don't know if my love for the film has
negatively impacted my view of this
but it feels like it really missed the
point of the source material
and instead of betraying an earnest
depiction of mental health
it turns it into a soap opera now i
think the american horror story hardcore
fans will love this
as it's very in line however as someone
who
you know though i enjoy the show i know
there's good and bad seasons
and i just feel like this is one that
missed the mark there's just so much
filler and things that feel alien to the
movie
that i have no idea why they even
bothered calling it a prequel
it could easily stand alone and it
probably wouldn't affect people's view
of it
i wanted to see what caused the ratchet
that we'd come to hate
but i just don't feel like i get that
here and it massively
just misses the point though it's not
bad
this season just feels completely
unnecessary and it gets a 5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you drop them
below
if you want to see one of our other
breakdowns then check out our review of
the latest episode of the boys which is
going to be linked at the end
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chatters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition not i'll tell you what i'll
see you next time
unless you hate this video in which case
i won't but take care
and have a good weekend i love you